renee dixon lives in indianapolis and
has worked in early childhood education
for 25 years and today she works as a
preschool director
but what makes her so special is that
she has spent
every weekend for the last four years
driving for uber in order to buy
supplies
gifts clothes for her students
i'm so excited to talk to her um renee
are you there i am how are you
[Music]
[Applause]
irene so nice to meet you it's i've been
so looking forward to meeting you
so how did you first become passionate
about education like what was there a
moment in your life was it over time
what was it
it was um i'm from mississippi so i used
to work at the mississippi state
penitentiary men death row
and i start seeing younger and younger
people
coming into the system and i said
something's wrong
somewhere someone missed something so
when i moved to indianapolis
i said i need to be there
i have to be there this is my caller to
be there for kids
and you think that's maybe like the
missing link as far as
if there is love consistency
availability yes um
resources yes that that will have
a trickle-down effect or matriculate as
they say in your world
into young adult yes
i mean in the first five years of a
child's life is the most important five
years
so and they learn so much their little
brains are like sponges and
and every little thing that you do and
every little science experiment
that you do with them it's it's amazing
even just putting vinegar
with baking soda they're like oh oh my
god how did you do that is that
[Music]
that's magic my daughter in a nutshell
every day all around the house she's mrs
i call her the alchemist uh anarchist
um what gave you the idea
then to start driving for uber on
weekends to raise money
well i worked for a company
they didn't really have a budget for the
classroom
and my students needed everything and
i'm i said
i have to be there i have to be that
person
so at least taking some of the load off
the parents
so i started doing that and then
christmas came and i bought
christmas presents but this last year
it was harder because covet
and a lot of my families who are living
below the poverty line
they told me they can afford christmas
presents for their kids
and i'm like no child should ever wake
up
not have christmas presents because i've
been there before
growing up my mom was a single mom and
i said nope your child is going to have
a christmas
and a christmas present and i tell them
i say and then if you have children
other children
they're going to have it so i have 50
students
and 20 siblings so 70 kids
i mean it was a lot of work but if
i didn't do it then who else because a
lot of parents
were used to being that giving person
and now they had to be the person that
received the help
and they were kind of embarrassed about
them like there's nothing to be
embarrassed about
everybody's gonna go through something
once in their life
i'm here i got it i tell them i got it i
got it i'm going to do it i'm going to
do it there a night so i'm like
you ain't going to do it i'm like i'm
going to do it i'm going to do it i'm
going to do it
i mean when i work seven to six monday
through fridays
and on fridays when i get off at six
o'clock
i guess my car up
work until one two o'clock in the
morning take a little nap
get up at eight sometimes nine drive
to one two o'clock sunday morning
take a little nap get up eight nine
o'clock
and drive to four o'clock on sundays and
then after four
i sleep i have so many thoughts and
feelings right now a i want to be your
best friend b
i want everyone to be like you see i'm
just so glad
that you're in the world that you grew
up with a single mom
that you worked on death row you saw a
discrepancy
you went and you studied and got your
degree in psychology and early child
education
became a teacher take care of the
students provide them with shoes clothes
shelter like love a good attitude and
then go and help their parents
and drive all weekend to fund it i i
i just had to do a recap because it's
just it's so
um incredible i mean it's something that
i have to do
it's something i have to do i just want
to say i thank you
for going above and beyond and um bp
wants to give you this five thousand
dollar gift
card that can be used at bp and amico
stations
and then we wanted to get something else
for your kids so today
kid pick the number one clothing
subscription box for kids
wants to donate another five thousand
dollars worth of winter clothing
for you and your students i haven't done
anything
i haven't done anything special you know
what renee
i don't think any of us are going to
even come close to measuring up to what
you do
so i i mean you're a teacher for a
reason because you're teaching a lot
more than your students
thank you guys so much i mean
do you really think that what you do is
like the bare minimum and not
special that's what you're supposed to
do
this is what you're supposed to do i was
always taught this is what you're
supposed to do
who taught you that may i ask my mom and
my aunts
and my grandmother they always say this
is what you're supposed to do
i just want everyone to be like you and
you are our teacher renee i can't thank
you enough
thank you and your mom and your aunt and
all your students and their family we
just send
so much love and gratitude to everyone
and
thank you to bp and kid pick thank you
so much to these companies thank you and
renee
we'll be in touch